exa uma parada maneira eu pelo menos
acha
acho não tenho certeza e tenho como
provar
existe uma fórmula que comprova isso
pegue qualquer coisa sobre um bicho que
ela fica maneira por exemplo areia a
coisa mais sem graça sozinha somam bicho
ok maneira que fica
eu curto muito os animais compartilhar
minha vida com eles
não é à toa trabalha há muitos anos com
cães e outros animais eles são o meu
sustento não só de grana mas mental e
emocional e isso parece ser genético
meu pai faleceu quando eu tinha apenas
três anos
eu não tenho nenhuma lembrança dele
minha mãe conta que ele era um amante
dos animais
adorava cães e passarinhos especialmente
os canalhas vitimado por um câncer
ele deixou seis filhos mas minha mãe
conta que meu pai sempre teve e esteve
com os animais vai deixar
mas minha mãe conta que meu pai sempre
teve e esteve com os animais ea dar um
rolê os cães tinham com ele seus cães
cuidavam da casa e do quintal
perambulavam soltos pelo bairro e
acompanhavam seus filhos na escola
eram outros tempos é engraçado perceber
o quanto nós estamos vinculados e
dependemos dos animais
nossa alimentação nossa economia enfim
uma porção de coisas inclusive eu
acredito que nós não estaríamos aqui se
não fosse em função dos cães
ok vocês podem estar pensando como assim
pensa comigo 15 a 20 mil anos atrás
o homem deixava de ser nômade e passava
viver em aldeias em grupos
esse é o início da agricultura o início
da criação de animais
o início da domesticação antes dos cães
o homem não podia dormir direito visto
constante risco de ataque de animais
selvagens ou outro grupo de humanos com
os cães
ao menor sinal de perigo ao redor das
aldeias
eles lá tinham ok mas o que tem isso a
ver com estarmos ou não estarmos aqui
dormindo melhor nossos anseios dos
nossos ancestrais desenvolveram seus
cérebros sua cultura sua comunicação sua
tecnologia e ficaram mais produtivos
é engraçado perceber como os animais
fazem parte da história tanto daquelas
que são contados pelos nossos avós né
estão presentes nas artes e até na
mitologia rômulo e remo fundadores de
roma foram abandonados dentro de um
cesto no rio tibre e foram resgatados e
amamentados por uma loba sentar
ouro metade homem metade cavalo
minotauro cabeça de touro corpo de homem
reduza seus cabelos são serpentes e
metade do seu corpo é uma cobra
nos dias atuais batman o homem morcego
mogli o menino lobo enfim exemplos não
faltam
o fato é que os animais fazem parte da
história da humanidade
falamos muito de cães porque esta foi a
espécie que melhor sucesso teve nesta
simbiose nesta vinculação com o ser
humano
pesquisas demonstram que cães
entendem os sinais gestuais dos humanos
melhor que nossos primos os grandes
primatas
em pesquisa recente descobriu que os
cães desenvolverem sua face
um músculo exclusivo para fazer a
carinha o pa a carinha de pidão
adaptação para se comunicar com o ser
humano
fato é que os animais fazem parte da
nossa história e estão presentes na mais
refinada filosofia emmanuel kant disse
podemos julgar o coração de um homem
pela forma com que ele trata os animais
e aqui ficamos devendo pra eles
estima se que hoje no brasil existam
mais de 30 milhões de animais
abandonados eu vou repetir pra vocês 30
milhões de animais abandonados
isso é mais que a população do estado de
minas gerais o segundo mais populoso do
brasil
e olha só o desperdício
eu não disse pra vocês que os cães fazem
parte da nossa história da nossa
filosofia e da nossa economia
segundo consta hoje no brasil há 139
milhões de pets 139 milhões de animais
de estimação
o mercado pet
brasileiro movimenta 38 bilhões de reais
a estimativa para este ano de 2019
é o segundo maior mercado pet do mundo
ficando atrás apenas dos estados unidos
incremente é este número mas 30 milhões
de animais
passaríamos fácil fácil de 50 bilhões de
reais
isso significa mais emprego mais renda
mais estudos mas desenvolvimento
científico e mais investimentos
e olha só eu só tô falando de animais de
estimação eu não coloquei neste número
os animais selvagens
nem os animais de criação então se você
parar pra pensar hoje no território
nacional têm mais bicho do que gente
aliás minha mãe sempre fala bicho dá
muito trabalho e eu hoje complementa
essa frase bicho dá muito trabalho e
gera renda
foi pensando neste contexto que resolvi
trabalhar com animais quase saindo da
faculdade de administração me preparava
para ser um gestor um coordenador um se
ou mas isso não me agradava é trabalhava
com papéis planilhas escritório mas nada
disso me trazia o mesmo prazer de estar
com os meus cães então foi assim que
decidi trabalhar com cães e como num
passe de mágica sabe tipo lei da atração
que assim que eu fiz esse pedido aliás
eu vou falar de lei da atração daqui a
pouquinho pra vocês que eu fiz esse
pedido e não deu nem um mês depois foi
demitido um baita back continhas pra
pagar boletim para vencer
e você tem que correr atrás comecei
passeando cães
56 cães para fazer a hora render
vendendo o almoço para comer na janta e
vamos que vamos
e foi neste neste contexto que eu
conheci a lady que foi a minha primeira
cliente
a lei de engrossava a fila dos 30
milhões de animais abandonados
vivia na rua e foi encontrada atropelada
em uma avenida de florianópolis entre a
vida ea morte sobreviveu sobreviveu
graças a pessoas que dedicam as suas
vidas aos animais foi adotada por uma
pessoa que tem um coração de ouro nessas
feirinhas que a gente vê hoje bastante
por aí e vocês podem notar que ela tá
com asinhas de anjo e foi justamente aí
neste momento que me acendeu a chama dos
cães da ajuda social
eu levava a lei de numa ação pessoas se
reuniam se vestiam de carteiros iam até
a casa de outras pessoas que estavam
tristes deprimidas ou para sandro por
algum tipo de dificuldade
essas pessoas levavam uma cartinha e
nesta cartinha continha uma mensagem de
amor esperança e de fé foi fácil
perceber o poder transformador dos
animais e cada vez mais eu me
interessava pelo tema e não demorou
muito tempo e lá estava lisa nossa
primeira cão de ajuda social
alisa atuou durante dez anos visitando
casas lares asilos e hospitais evento
alisa trabalhar a sua atuação ficou
claro perceber o cón
quantos de benefícios os animais trazem
para a saúde dos humanos inclusive os
cientistas e pesquisadores têm até um
termo para isso
zoe zoei ação os benefícios positivos a
saúde seja física social e mental e
psicológica de pessoas que convivem ou
interagem com animais e os impactos no
bem estar dos indivíduos das famílias e
da sociedade
mas assim pra ficar mais fácil explicar
esse conceito pra vocês
pensa comigo zoonoses doenças causadas
ou transmitidas por animais
usoyan benefícios à saúde causados ou
transmitidos pelos animais
tanto a leite quanto à lisa já viraram
estrelinha para ajudar o papai do céu
nesse trabalho maravilhoso mas a lista
não partiu sem antes deixar um
substituto
o messi o messi veio pra mim meio
mauzinho desacreditado seu pêlo tava
todo embolado ea gente precisava
trabalhar bastante seus traumas seus
medos e sua insegurança
eu não disse pra vocês que a lei da
atração funciona muito bem pra mim em
2016 recebi uma mensagem me contando de
algo horrível era uma mãe de duas
crianças autistas me pedindo um cachorro
ela me contou que uma das crianças havia
apanhado na escola da professora e de
uma assistente sim um show de horror na
hora
o sangue sobe e eu falei
comigo mas aqui tem um detalhe do
detalhe importante quando você vai fazer
um pedido para o universo e utilizar a
lei da atração você não pode dar vacilo
o pedido tem que ser certeiro senão
universo entrega aquilo que ele entendeu
então olha só eu não pedi um cachorro
para ser treinado entregue para a
família da criança que tinha sofrido
abuso físico o que eu pedi um cachorro
para ajudar as crianças e muitas o messi
ajuda jovens adultos e idosos não
importa o messi ajuda todo mundo eo
messi
ele acaba sendo fruto de uma série de
decisões erradas que eu tomei a primeira
decisão errada foi que selecionar um
cachorro adulto para esse trabalho
o segundo é que não fiz uma seleção
super técnica foi movido muito mais pela
emoção do que pela razão e terceiro
eu sabia que ele poderia vir em
engrossar a fila de 30 milhões de
animais abandonados
peguei foram seis meses só para
reequilibrar lo emocionalmente um ano
pra quê ensinar com todo o carinho e
cuidado o que ele precisava saber
mas valeu a pena de um pedido mal feito
e de uma série de decisões erradas
o messi se tornou
a melhor parte de mim ele é minha ponte
que me liga as pessoas que mais
necessitam daquelas pessoas que mais se
sentem desamparados ou simplesmente
daquelas que por um segundo por um
instante precisam só sentir amor ou se
sentir amada
eu não disse pra vocês que bicho era uma
parada maneira eu não dizer pra vocês
que tem uma fórmula para isso é só pegar
qualquer coisa e somar um bicho que ela
fica maneira pega uma casa de repouso
para pessoas idosas e sou um bicho
olha só que maneira
pegue uma sala de aula cheia de alunos e
some um bicho
olha só que maneiro pegue uma biblioteca
uma professora disposta uma criança e
some um bicho
olha só que maneira eu curto muito os
animais inclusive o bicho humano que
anda judiando e também anda muito
judiado tem uma fila de 30 milhões de
animais abandonados só esperando a
oportunidade de fazer a alegria ea
felicidade de uma infinidade de bicho
humano e agora vocês já sabem a fórmula
é só pegar qualquer coisa e somar um
bicho que ela fica maneira